die flutkatastrophe von deutschland
fordert bisher mehr als 40 tote dutzende
menschen werden noch vermisst
dauerregen setzt ganze ortschaften unter
wasser lässt flüsse über die ufer treten
zerstört straßen und häuser dieser
exklusiven live aufnahmen aus dem bild
helikopter zeigen das ganze ausmaß der
zerstörung
besonders betroffen nordrhein-westfalen
und rheinland-pfalz notstand in mehreren
regionen besonders dramatisch die lage
in der kleinen stadt schuld die sich
sonst idyllisch durch den 660 einwohner
ort schlängelt ist zu einem reißenden
strom geworden
sechs häuser stürzen ein weitere sind
einsturzgefährdet waren froh dass wir
dann auch im haus wir haben ein paar
sachen in den ersten stock gitarre und
dann sind wir zum nachbar der vatterodt
dadurch seien sie es nach ausnahme die
lage in schuld ist nach wie vor
unübersichtlich
aufgerissene straßen eingestürzte mauern
freiliegende versorgungsrohr das ist die
altstadt von bad münstereifel am tag
nach der flutkatastrophe ist überall in
den schlamm
was darüber weiter runter sind sogar
häuser weggenommen
also es
notstand wie im zweiten block ist
schlimmer als nach einem bombenangriff
und das wird garantiert zehn jahre
die menschen sind alle pleite die
geschäfte haben also es ist nur noch
graue wer durch die innenstadt will der
muss klettern die fußwege sie existieren
zu großen teilen nicht mehr die wasser
und stromversorgung ist seit der nacht
in weiten teilen der stadt unterbrochen
mit welcher ungeheuren kraft sich das
wasser derzeit seinen weg durch das
katastrophengebiet band zeigen diese
bilder aus rech an der ahr in diese
brücke einschlagen und wahrscheinlich
dabei zerstört werden
hoffentlich ist dieser wohnwagen lehrer
ist noch ein vorteil dran den zerreißt
in diesem moment den arzt quasi wie
durch die müllpresse hat es diesen
wohnwagen durch den brückenbogen der
sand nepomukbrücke durchgezogen wir
stehen jetzt hier mitten im stadtteil
stotzheim in der stadt euskirchen wo das
unwetter heute nacht auch gewütet ist
wir sprechen jetzt einmal mit anwohner
udo schmitz herr schmitz wie haben sie
die nacht hinter sich gebracht wie haben
sie das erlebt was ist passiert hier im
ortsteil ja sie sind immer wieder die
ganze nach den abstimmungen das ist wie
in einem schlechten film
ich sag mal d day after tomorrow sind
immer nur daran wo ist was sie schon
überall etwas grausam sie haben es noch
nicht gesehen so was wie ist jetzt hier
die situation aktuell wie wie kämpfen
sie hier gegen die schäden an
ja so wie ich das beurteilen kann jeder
hilft dem anderen ich bin eine eine
gemeinschaft jetzt her und einige sind
wir sind gott sei dank ein bisschen
verschont geblieben deshalb ist mein
bruder her und versuchen das beste
daraus zu machen
land unter auch in altena in nrw hier
werden straßen zu reißenden flüssen
autos wie spielzeug weggespült nordrhein
westfalens ministerpräsident armin
laschet macht sich vor ort selbst ein
bild von der lage
eine botschaft an die menschen
wir tun alles um jetzt zu helfen
krisenstäbe werden koordiniert das
funktioniert vor ort sehr gut
und wir werden recht zügig mit der
gesamten landesregierung
wie man auch den regionen nach der
beheben werden unmittelbaren schäden auf
dauer helfen auch am donnerstag gibt es
keine aussicht auf entspannung für die
krisengebiete wurden weitere
niederschläge angekündigt
[Musik]
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren